Bell's Bourbon and bullets a Murder
Mystery Dinner Party game it is so much
fun Everybody Plays a character we go
around the room we try to figure out who
did it hey I'm wondering if this is a
terrible idea this is my call Jim big
picture stuff it's about murder I
thought we agreed that we wouldn't do
things like this tube City you owe me
one
co-managing is a give and take you have
to pick your battles one of the battles
that I picked was to stop Michael from
running plastic tubes all over the
office and placing hamsters inside of
them
he was going to call it Tube City
so yes I do owe him one
I have noticed that we welcome
thank you I've noticed we've been having
a lot of conference room meetings and
I'm wondering if perhaps those are a bit
um disruptive yes no I don't think they
are I think the meetings are very
important okay maybe we should talk
specifics let's do okay
yesterday we had a meeting about planets
well to be fair Jim James
jimothy
to be fair Timothy that sounds weird are
you okay with being called Jim I am
I confirmed with Raskin design and
they're expecting that both of you in an
hour oh actually it's just gonna be me
they said the both of you
that's a mistake you should give him a
call check that out all right just clear
this up well there's actually been a few
changes in the company and Michael and I
are actually at the same level
so I no
no why would that be a problem she was a
good kid he could handle a lot but
sometimes you have to call on a master
I
why would you date an amateur when you
could date a professional
great see you then
what what they said that they would feel
more comfortable if you came along why
don't they just want you to go by
yourself why do they want me to come to
I don't understand I absolutely don't
understand either I don't want you to
feel like I'm babysitting you or
something
all right all right let me go get your
stroller
oh
sure Michael's a good teacher
a teacher is someone who stands right
next to your whole life and never lets
you do anything
that's what his teacher is right
[Music]
thank you
everything
is we have to do something because
people are losing it out there wondering
what's gonna happen
okay we need some sort of distraction
for everybody anything new on YouTube
Michael doesn't even need to be good
oh God I can't think I need more Mullins
could you please sign my expense report
no way know how expense reports are a
day-to-day item that is gyms now I am
exclusively big picture Epic
science
where's the please we're not animals
sign it no not without a please
idiot
I have a complaint about Jim that is not
big picture
I would like to file a huge enormous
massive complaint about the tallest guy
in our office
okay
Jim won't sign my expense report that is
not okay
get out get out get out get out
I'd like to launch a complaint I'm sorry
to hear about that who is this about you
okay just want to let you know I take
complains very seriously so
when did this happen one minute ago okay
and how do you feel
angry all right did he hit you no did
you cry no you feel like crying no I'm
just gonna write held back tears wait
stop writing that that is not true if
you stop crying I'll stop writing I'm
not huh
hey any messages you're soaking wet oh
well Jim and I got caught in a little
flash rain flash winds flash lightning
wow sounds scary it was it was and then
in an instant it wasn't why isn't Jim
what I outran it I don't think it rained
my hip would be throbbing it rained
Michael can I get you something a towel
some cocoa nothing
Coco I'll just leave that suit in your
office then good yep
you're sure it was water it couldn't
have been acid I already declared you it
was too dark to tell stop playing games
with me this is not a game this is my
life you are out of order answer me you
are out of all you are out of order I
think Michael may have snapped or maybe
he's just stuck in character well which
is worse snapped or stuck
both
they're both worse
um Michael the custodian from Raskin
design is on the line he said they found
your keys in the koi pond okay thank you
did you say koi pond
yeah Michael you are asking questions
hey Michael did you fall into a koi pond
ah I can't really hear you I think we
have sort of a bad connection Jim did
Michael fall into a koi pond
um
it's like Michael said it was um
some something else it was okay this is
what it was it was these bunch of idiots
that had put a fish tank in the ground
with no cover and no railing so you fell
in no maybe I was trying to save a child
that had fallen in so a child had fallen
in not yet that is hilarious no it don't
I'm not gonna bump I'm not gonna bump
and it was not hilarious it was very
very terrifying
Michael can I
okay I'm just gonna skip right past the
what and go with why because this is the
recreation of a crime scene I'm the dead
body and these are my brain challenge
hey shut up you're dead Michael can I
talk to you no Michael here
today
shut up they need this game Jim
let us have this stupid little game all
right
you know the more I think about it the
more I think
salesman
that will not go over well yeah I know I
just think it seems smart to keep the
salesman happy right now of course I
know that this might come off as biased
so you know what let us oh my God are
you gonna make another pro and con
listen to kill myself I'm not gonna let
you stop me from thinking you know
there's no easy way to do this I say
if we add 1.5 percent to their paychecks
and don't say anything about it do you
mean like breaking in the middle of the
night and change the numbers on payroll
no we can do it during the day it
doesn't have to be that dramatic Jim
okay
you know what would help is pros and
cons list for our options Jim don't take
this the wrong way are you gonna take
this the wrong way
it's hard to tell so far you use your
brain too much I'm sorry are you
advocating that I use it less sometimes
the smartest people don't think at all
you just came up with that as I was
saying yeah
okay so for the 1.5 increase Pro
everyone gets a little bit Khan you look
like a nerd con no one gets as much as
they did last year Pro you get to share
your pros and cons lists with the other
nerds Pro no favoritism Cod you unzip
your pants and you'll find that there's
a calculator out there
I've been studying Michael for years and
I've condensed what I've learned into
this chart
how Michael spends his time as you can
see we have procrastinating and
distracting others and this tiny sliver
here is critical thinking
I made it bigger so that you could see
it
it's actually not the first time I've
been embarrassed by a pond
well in high school the girls volleyball
team always used to throw me into the
frozen lake four years in a row
oh it was freezing no no no no no oh
this is even worse couple weeks ago I
went to get a new cell phone and I
wanted one of those packages where you
have the five you know the friends
friends and family thing and the guy was
like who are your five friends and I'm
like ah I didn't even know I couldn't
even think oh my God it was so
embarrassing that was whoa
I don't even have Jan's cell phone
number and I hate her you won't give it
to me
I was like oh I guess I'm a loser
too far God
thanks a lot man
thanks for the advice